it just so happens that later this week
just a couple of days after the uvalde
texas school shooting the most deadly
school shooting since sandy hook in
2012. that happened in texas and later
this week the national rifle association
the largest and most most powerful
gun rights lobby what they mean is gun
manufacturer lobby they work from the
gun manufacturers to sell as many guns
as possible the nra is having its
convention in houston texas the shooting
happened in texas the nra is having its
convention in texas and who is scheduled
to attend that convention well donald
trump is scheduled to speak there and
ted cruz is scheduled to speak there
republican texas senator and greg abbott
is scheduled to speak there the
republican texas governor
just days after the uvalde mass shooting
these three republicans who advocate for
more guns in more places and say guns
aren't the problem and we need more guns
they're going to show up and speak
presumably in praise
of the national rifle association which
has been one of the most important
corporate organizations that's what they
are
at putting more guns in more places
making guns easier to access easier to
buy and allowed uh in more places in
american society
how do they do it
and what will they say how do they
justify their presence there how do you
justify the existence of the nra in this
context this is a celebration of guns
this is a place that celebrates
making it easy for people to obtain
firearms and just about any type of
firearm that they would want
by the way guns will not be allowed at
donald trump's speech they may also not
be allowed at greg abbott's speech now
um
the
of they always like to say well that's
secret services decision
okay well
needless to say if guns make everybody
super safe
then why is it a danger to anyone even
if it's secret service saying we don't
allow guns around the president
if this is an organization premised on
the notion
that more guns make people safe you
would think the safest that the
president would be
would be around a room full of people
with guns because if any crazy bad guy
with a gun thought to do anything there
would be so many good guys with guns
there
to stop him
uh bizarre all absolutely bizarre
um it's very strange also by the way
that when these events happen all of a
sudden the nra also goes to our thoughts
and prayers and all these different
things they're certainly not going to
bring up their role in making firearms
easier to access and the cycle with the
nra is as follows and as i've said
before
the nra uh wins
whether there are lots of shootings or
whether there are not and here's the way
it works
it's actually genius in a way
if there's no mass shootings for a while
which i mean it's like this is the
united states there's always mass
shootings but let's i'll i'll pr i'll
kind of qualify that by saying if
there's no mass shooting that gets
national news for a week because there's
mass shootings basically every day in
the united states but if we go a while
without one of these
major quote major mass shootings like
buffalo sandy hook or more recently in
uvalde the gun rights people will say
it's thanks to guns
the reason that we are not having that
many mass shootings and what means that
many by the way it's a sick standard but
they'll say people are not going out and
doing mass shootings because they know
others might be armed
the shooters don't want to go out there
and have their plans foiled by a good
guy with a gun now at the same time they
want to say that the shooters are all
simply mentally ill
if they are simply mentally ill they're
probably not rationally thinking well
i shouldn't go and do a shooting because
there might be a good guy with a gun
mentally ill people if you believe their
story wouldn't be thinking that way but
regardless if you have fewer mass
shootings they say it's thanks to guns
if you start to see more mass shootings
right they say this is a reminder
this is evidence
that everybody's got to be armed because
it's so dangerous out there we need more
firearms and then of course the classic
is if there's a mass shooting and
there's a democrat in the white house
like joe biden
the nra will announce
democrats and joe biden are coming for
your guns ted cruz is already saying it
others are already saying it they're
coming for your guns so you damn well
better get out there and buy some more
firearms and then the gun manufacturers
make massive profits the gun
manufacturers profit from mass shootings
there were record gun sales under obama
after sandy hook why well it's dangerous
out there there was a mass shooting so
you need guns to keep yourself safe and
barack obama is going to try to take
your guns away and then it is rinse
repeat rinse repeat time and time again
so are trump cruz and or abbott going to
bail on speaking at the nra convention i
don't know as of right now they're still
scheduled to speak what will they say
uh
i can only imagine
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
15 off all products and free shipping go
to vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below